The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GANG CHEN: So this is
Nano-to-Macro Transport
Process, 2.570 for undergraduate
students and 2.57 for graduate
student.
And it's offered
every two years.
So I'm glad to say, this is
probably the largest audience
I've ever had.
And so I'm very pleased to
say the growing popularity.
The last time we did
OpenCourseWare I think
was in 2004.
And that one, we had voice
recording and typewritten
notes.
And you can still go to
the MIT OpenCourseWare
if you miss a lecture, I think.
Although we do have changes,
The changes are not dramatic.
So you can go there
and try to make them up
if you miss any lectures.
And this semester MIT
has a new initiative
trying to put the
course or video online.
And so I volunteered.
And also that way people
can read my book better.
It's a hard book to read.
And in addition
to my book, there
are also a list
of books recommend
because you'll see
that this course really
cover a wide range of topics.
So we have given a list of
references for each subject.
You can always go
to other books.
This is not
necessarily the easiest
to understand but to say we put
it on reserve in the library.
And with that, I
think, it's pretty much
the housekeeping item done.
And what I'm going to do next
is to give you some slide.
I'm not going to show
slides every week.
But I'm going to
give you some slides
to see what's the
scope of this course
and some motivational slide.
¿So any questions?
If you look at the title, this
is Nano-to-Macro Transport
Process.
So we're emphazising nano,
we're emphasizing transport,
we're also emphasizing the
transition from nano to macro.
So this is a slide from
a colleague of mine.
And here we're showing
the length scales--
that's in nature-- and length
scales for what we make,
artificially.
Later of course, we
have the biological side
you can see going
from molecules to DNA
to bacteria cells and
progressively increase
and then scale.
And then if we look at what
people are making, for example,
these nanoparticles--
sometimes we
call them quantum dots as small
as a few, 1 to 5 nanometers
and to nanowires and
nanoelectronics, where this is
actually quite a few year old.
I think the gate length
in semiconductors
now is just around a few
tenths, 10, 20 nanometers.
So those are the--
we're making smaller
and smaller devices.
And of course at the end,
what we're interfacing
is at the macro scale.
So when we go to small
scales, the questions,
because you have learned a
lot in the transport theory,
for example--
the question is are
they valid or not
and if they are not valid,
what are the alternatives.
And also, we're
not just to looking
at the individual nanoparticles.
When you put them
together into macro scale,
what's the picture there?
So this is where this course
is trying to wrestle with.
And that's in fact--
most of my research is
looking into thinking
how we can look at the
small and then how using
the small to do the big things.
Particularly, most of
the work I'm working on
is heat transfer related
to energy and energy
as a large scale, so how I can
take small to go to the large.
And let me give you two
examples from research
to show that when
you go to nanoscale,
the classical theory that
you have learned breaks down.
And the first example is
a heat conduction example.
We know in heat conduction
we have Fourier law.
And we have thermal
conductivity of the materials.
And this is one example of nano.
This is in fact transmission
electron microscope
image of a layered structure.
One layer, the bright
layer is silicon.
The darker layer is germanium.
So each layer is
about 2 nanometers.
And then when you measure
thermal conductivity--
so you can take a silicon
because one layer is silicon.
The other is germanium.
So you have started
heat transfer.
It's parallel plates.
And then you can do
thermal resistors
to say what's the effect
with thermal conductivity.
And you can say if I
take a silicon germanium
thermal conductivity,
I will predict
that's the equivalent thermal
energy of those open circles.
But the experimentally measured
dots are order of magnitude
smaller.
And in fact, we have to go
to complete different theory.
In this case, we have to
go to Boltzmann equation
to predict now--
See, this is a work that we
started in 90's, and now we're
doing quantum calculations
on those structures.
So there's significant departure
from the classical theory
when you go to nano scales.
And as another
example, you learned
in thermal radiation,
[? black ?] body
is the maximum of
thermal radiation.
But, see, say when
we go to nanoscale,
when we put the two objects
smaller, the distance-- this
was on MIT web page.
I really like this.
They're very creative.
What should I say?
This is better than what we did.
So that's Planck's law,
black body radiation.
And that's usually
considered maximum.
And when we put two
surfaces down to nanoscale--
right here is one micron, 100
nanometer, and 10 nanometer.
We can go beyond
the Planck's law
by several order of magnitude.
When I say this is three
order of magnitude--
we're now at the four
order of magnitude.
And we're looking at what
happens between that one
nanometer and contact.
And you say, why you cares?
The fact is when I put
many materials together,
they say it's
really particularly
when I'm doing nano.
It's really the
interface dominance.
And so that interface
sometimes contact each other.
Sometimes they do not.
So this is the
[? connection. ?] I say,
how I can take this
nanoscale and eventually
go to macro scale?
So this is a propaganda.
I do nano.
I say, once I was asked
by a graduate student,
summarize research
in three words.
That's what I came
up, nano heat, energy.
And what I had benefited
over the years is--
I'm a mechanical engineer.
I always say at the end, I
do want to be useful, right.
So I think about atoms, but
I also think about continuum.
And I say we have few
things that we can probably
claim that we had really done
some change in the materials.
I gave an example on this
thermal conductivity,
[? second ?] germanium
superlattice,
that layer structure.
And we're taking that to make a
better thermal electric energy
converters because we need the
materials with the pool heat
conduction, and we still need
the electron goes through.
So this is a very
contradictory requirement.
And currently we're
working on this photon side
that we're designing
nanostructure
using less material
to do solar cells.
And we have some of the
most conductive liquid
just by putting
nanoparticles in the liquid
and find out what's the
thermal conductivity.
In fact, at the end we say,
I don't want everything nano.
That's where you understand
if you understand physics--
now that's everything is nano.
So we work on people putting
nanoparticle into liquid.
Some say have high
thermal conductivity.
Others go to lab, they say,
no, we can't measure it.
We struggled for four years
and eventually figured out--
we say, OK, eventually what we
need is macro in one direction
and nano in the other direction.
And that's how we achieve the
best thermal conductivity.
And we also have the
most conductive polymers.
I get a call every month
almost from an industry to say,
can we have it?
So the question was polymers,
plastics, are typically
poor heat condition.
So people always want to
make them more conductive.
Most work is making them
more electrically conductive.
But, see, when we
ask the question,
I got a call from
Intel saying can you
think about how I can
better manage a hit.
I started thinking
of plastics and how
I make them more conductive.
And if you look at how
people usually do it,
they'll put in a composite.
They'll put a lot of component
and make them average peak
and higher heat conduction.
And when I think about
this, OK, of course
that's one of the approach.
But, see, the question we
ask is a molecule, a polymer,
really a poor conductor?
Is a molecular chain
a pool heat conductor?
If you think of a polyethylene,
which is 60% of the plastics.
And it's a carbon
per carbon bonding.
And carbon-carbon,
what's the highest
of the thermal
conductivity material?
Anyone know?
STUDENT: Diamond.
GANG CHEN: Diamond,
carbon-carbon bond.
So that suggests in the
molecular chain direction,
I should have a high heat
thermal conductivity.
So you think about the nano.
You think about molecules.
And in fact, I say,
of course, I can put
that in more fancier theory.
I go to Fermi, and he
did work in the '50s.
And he said
one-dimensional conductor
has an infinite
thermal conductivity.
So that gave me a lot of
motivation to look into that.
And in turn, we did succeed
in actually creating
the most conductive polymer.
Except, it's in one
single fiber, nanofiber.
All right, so I say--
I got calls every
month from company.
I said, you guys have to
wait or you give me money.
We do more research because
I need to scale this up,
because you eventually are
not using single nanofiber
to put in your heat exchangers.
So that's what I say.
You need to think of nano.
You have a lot of.
You can generate more
new ideas but also
to think to how you
can go to macro.
So when I say, what's
nano for energy.
If you think about
the energy, at the end
it's molecules that mechanical
engineer are familiar with.
It's the electrons, and
it's a photon, the light
or its lattice vibration phonon.
Those are the basic
energy carrier.
There are some other terms.
But let's say those are
the basic energy carriers.
What's their characteristic
length, the mean free pass
and the wavelengths?
So the mean free
pass of air molecule
will get into that very strong.
In this room it's
about 100 nanometer.
And that means they travel about
100 nanometer and the collide
with another molecule.
And the wavelengths of
light, visible light.
How much wavelengths?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: 400 nanometer
to 700 nanometer range,
so half micron.
And so a lot of this
in the nanometer range.
And if you think about
energy, fundamentally,
if you can control the
energy level a material has--
for example, if I make a
quantum dots that I show before,
5 nanometer spheres,
particles, what happens
is an electron, quantum
mechanics-- it's a wave.
And wave has a wavelength.
And typical wavelengths is
let's say, 10 nanometer.
Now a wave of 10
nanometer, you try
to fit into that 5 nanometer
quantum dot what happens.
You squeeze that wave.
You squeeze that wave the
energy level will change.
So if you look at professor
Moungi Bawendi's home page,
you will see the quantum
dots of different colors.
That's because the
energy level change
when you make the size change.
So that's one way you
can control the energy.
If you control the energy, now
come to mechanical engineering
or any engineering.
What are you doing?
You control the thermodynamics.
Energy is the most fundamental.
So you can control
thermodynamics.
And the other is,
let's say, transport.
If you look at where
the losses are.
If you say, OK,
second law of color.
Let's say you can get to
color efficiency, pretty good.
If you can get all
color efficiency,
you should all be pleased.
But, we lose about 60%
of a useful energy.
If you look at the energy,
input, output, and color.
Let's say you can
get to [? 90%. ?]
So you can improve
the transport if you
can control the energy carrier
traveling, their interaction,
their traveling.
So I said that the air molecule
is about 100 nanometers,
the mean free path.
And that seems so awfully small.
But if you open
your computer, you
look at the hard disk, the
separation between the disk
itself, which is
rotating about 10,000
RPM and the magnetic head is a
few nanometers, few nanometers
in everybody's computer.
So you go to this disk
drive company, and that they
have gave up the--
because it's basically
how to allow the crash
that disk had with the disk.
It's a full mechanic's problem.
And they have given up solving
the Navy Stokes fishing
because fluid mechanics, that's
solving Navy Stokes equation.
k They don't use it enough.
A long time ago
they've given up.
And on day, they
call me, they say,
we have one nanometer problem.
I said, what nanometer?
At the time, I didn't
know even the separation.
I said, why do
you care about it?
Because at the time there were
about 20 nanometer separation.
I'm going to say that's
already 5% uncertainty.
And now they are going beyond--
they are below 10 nanometers.
We still didn't figure out
whether it was that 1 nanometer
problem.
So but there are a lot of--
So basically using the
boundaries and this regime,
you need to go to
different laws.
So whether we're
talking in this course
and in this book are really--
this is my view of trying
to have a picture from nano
to the continuum.
And firstly, you need to
understand the basic energy
states.
The energy level
is in the material.
So that really need the
quantum mechanic solid states.
And then I do a
heat transfers, I
need to bring in
the temperature.
That's a statistic
thermal energy.
And then we need to look at
how those energy carrier moves.
So that's the transport.
In transport, you
have continuum laws.
You have also--
You need to go to
the long continuum.
You need to vary weather.
You need to see
in quantum regime
where you have to
look at the wave later
or you can forget about it.
So what I would like to have
is to develop that picture.
If you have a problem
and people come to you
and say, well, in this regime,
I'm varying the weather,
I can still use the continuum.
If you feel comfortable to tell
them, yeah, there's no problem,
just go, you may get
10% error, 20% error.
But at least say, I want
to develop the comfort
level of when you can use,
say, what kind of transport
pictures.
And in fact, I say, if
you look at the book,
it's a parallel treatment.
Say for electrons,
molecules, photons, phonons.
So that's the way I understand
the object, the subject.
And I've been always
a mechanical engineer.
I first learned thermal
radiation, photons,
and of course, I learned
all this continuum theory.
And it turns out that if you
understand the one carrier,
you can make a rudder.
It's easy, relatively easy
analogy for other carriers.
And at least in this so-called
the dilute gas picture,
the behavior are very similar.
So this is what I'm most
familiar with a wave Maxwell
equation.
But, see, this is where most
engineers familiar with,
Ohms law, Fourier's law,
Newton's Shear Stress
law, this other continuum.
But, say, if I go
to photon radiation,
where if you think about the
photon from the sun to Earth,
you don't got to solve
diffusion question for that.
In fact, I say, the surplus
is just a straight trajectory,
ballistic.
This will happens if
I have a disk drive.
I have a disk, the example here.
Averagely speaking, the
molecule travel 100 nanometer.
And now the molecule, if there
is a molecule in the gap,
they'll collide the wall.
They don't collide
with each other.
That's a ballistic
transport picture.
So what we want to
have is developing,
say, when I need to
think about the wave,
when I need to think about the--
forget about the wave
but, say, it still
needed to say what's
the boundary effects
and eventually,
say, the continuum.
So it's a very--
The challenge for
this is most of you--
I know most of my students,
they are mechanical engineers,
with mechanical
engineering background.
And that's where we're most
familiar with, most comfortable
with.
And what we add to this
is a lot of new subjects
and typically take
many years to build up.
It took myself many
years to build up.
So I'm very ambitious to say, I
want to teach you one semester.
You will be inundated
with terminology.
OK.
And also, but what I'm hoping is
at the end you gain something.
You can look and say I
have a sense of from nano
from molecules to the continuum.
So that's what we have in
the general introduction
any questions.
I want to feel free
to ask questions
before I turn off the
computer because I'll do that.
Every week I actually spend at
the end of lecture 10 minutes
or so to have some relaxation
time, relaxing time.
And what I want to show you is--
I don't know how many
of you go to journals.
And then most of you
are graduate students.
And you should go to journal
every week and if not every day
and just to look at what
other people are doing.
So when you are a
new graduate student,
you don't go to journal often.
And you go to journal,
you look at it.
Most of this stuff you
don't understand, other
than the ones--
If you work on heat transfer,
it goes journal heat transfer.
Maybe you know what
these people are talking.
So, say, if I want to
start with any journal,
not medical, not biomedical.
I'm not familiar with that.
Any other journal, you tell me.
And I want to see, OK,
where are you at this today
and where you are at
the end of the semester.
And my ambition
is for you to say,
look at the paper title and 50%
say, maybe I can take a look.
Maybe I am not
completely ignorant.
So give me the
name of a journal.
Later.
OK, let's take a look.
So the wow for the challenge of
nature is that now most of them
actually biological.
But that's fine.
Let's still say what's
the news this week.
STUDENT: Social network.
GANG CHEN: Huh?
STUDENT: There was one
about social networks.
GANG CHEN: Social
network, social network.
I want you to think about the
entropy of social network.
All right, I tell you at
the end, I only need--
if your career at the
end, you say, OK, there
are only three words
you need to understand,
not just nano, heat, and energy.
Now, only three words
you need to understand,
energy, momentum, and entropy.
OK.
If you feel comfortable
with that, let's look at--
Let's see, where are the
technical papers there?
Research, [INAUDIBLE]
those are the--
I want to go more
into the plasma.
What is plasma?
And so when I look
at this, quantum
coherence the coupling of
a mechanical oscillator
to optical cavity mode.
I look at that paper.
I haven't read it.
Clearly, what I was thinking--
Anybody want to guess what
they will be talking about?
So you will say, I don't know.
OK, so my guess is they
were probably related
to force, momentum of photons.
It's mechanical.
And so it turns out that
the photon has the momentum,
and it carries force.
Anything that has momentum
can generate force.
So optical cavity, so you
will learn this stuff, OK.
So the quantum control,
I'm not very familiar.
But what I can say is the
optical cavity, the modes
and also, the
coherency issue we'll
talk, not exactly
related to photon
but related to
transport, how I can
go from that normally the
wave of a coherent state
to eventually I can forget
about the coherence of the waves
and treat them as particles.
So my point is to
say at the end, what
I'm hoping is that you'll open
a journal like Applied Physics
and Nano Letters or Science and
Literature, you're not scared.
OK.
There are a lot of terminologies
that you probably didn't know,
and they'll stick to
you and through to you.
And maybe you'll
remember something.
OK, so let's start
talking more details.
So what I want to
start with is for you
to think about what are
the laws you have learned.
Let's see what are they--
OK, I want to get the--
So we talked about briefly--
you just follow my syllabus.
We show the slides on
motivations and scope.
Now let's go to classical laws,
not necessarily classical.
I just want to
say, what have they
lost that you think
that you have learned.
And particularly I
like to transport.
STUDENT: Conservation law.
GANG CHEN: OK, let's start
with the conservation.
So I'll use this side.
We have conservation.
What are the conservation laws?
You have mass
conservation, momentum.
What are the other?
Energy, first law.
Other?
Charge.
So charge on what?
Charge transport?
Oh, conservation of charge.
OK, yeah.
STUDENT: Parity.
GANG CHEN: Parity.
I'm not familiar with that.
OK, yeah, I heard the
[? line. ?] What are others?
We're not going to touch
much on conservation laws.
I [? understand ?] [? saying ?]
that anything can be broken
except the first and second law.
So I'm not going to
touch much [? on it. ?]
OK.
We'll say, OK, even though
it's not a conservation
by the second law,
let's say you can
write the entropy generation.
You can still write
the equation there.
So those are the things
we don't touch much.
And there are
discussions in literature
saying you can break
the second law,
meaning the time,
very short time scale,
and statistically speaking,
you could have divisions.
That's possible.
And let's look at transport.
Tell me more on the
transport laws you learned.
So let's say you learn--
some of you are familiar
with heat, some of you
may be familiar with the
charge or fluids or mass.
Tell me the laws in
those disciplines.
OK, so let's do heat.
Heat in terms of the
laws, the Fourier law
is for heat condition.
So conduction, this course,
I put a prerequisite
at the 2005 five level.
And 2005 from other department
is basic heat conduction,
heat transfer thermal
fluids course.
And in other department
there is also, of course,
nanoengineering.
If you've taken that,
this will be easier
because there are a lot of--
there's some overlap.
But say, if not, you
can still survive.
So heat conduction,
we have the simplest
picture when one side is hot,
the other side is a cold.
And there's a heat flow inside.
And the law governing
the heat conduction,
I write the simplest
form is the Fourier law.
Fourier of heat
conduction, the heat flux
equals thermal conductivity
times temperature gradient.
And this is one dimension
that I'm reading.
And this is a heat flux.
The unit here is a
watt meter squared.
And the thermal conductivity
is a mature property
at the macro scale.
When you go to [? nano, ?]
you'll find this
is no longer material
property because it's
structure dependent.
But the unit of that is
watt per meter per Kelvin.
And then we just said
diamond is the most heat
conductive material.
And in fact, some
people would say
it's the carbon
nanotube of graphene.
So this is on the nanoscale.
On one side they
can go very high.
And the other side--
they give an example-- it
can go very low.
So this is one of the
laws, transport laws.
And this is the
conservation law.
And for this law,
what do we call?
[? Constituent ?] relation,
[? the ?] relation between
temperature and the heat flux.
And those [? constituent ?]
relations, many of them
have their regime of validity.
And then you can--
It's a law, you can brake them.
OK.
And so since we're doing heat,
what are the other heat laws?
OK.
And let's say convection.
So for convection, of
course, for those who know
Navier-Stokes equation, and
you need these very complicated
partial differentiable
equations--
but in the simplest picture
when we do convection is
I have a heated surface.
Let's say this is a wall.
And I have a fluid.
And away from the wall the
fluid temperature is Ta ambient.
And then I write
the law for cooling
is q equals h Tw minus Ta.
This is Newtons law of cooling,
Newton's law of cooling.
And h here is the heat
transfer coefficient.
The unit of age is
different from k
if you look at what we
had for Fourier law,
and it's watt meter
squared per Kelvin?
h is not a material property.
It depends on how fast is the
fluid, what fluid that you use,
and the geometry.
So for that you need to go
to a Navier-Stokes equation
to solve if the case is simple.
If its case is
complicated, you've
got to do the experiment.
And then one thing
I want to remind you
if you do fluids
problem or heat transfer
convection, on the wall you
often invoke a condition.
What is that condition?
STUDENT: Low slip.
GANG CHEN: Low slip.
So the velocity of molecule
is 0 or equal to the velocity
of the wall and the
temperature of the wall.
That's the low slip boundary
recognition and area view.
[INAUDIBLE] fluids or heat
transfer [? knows ?] that.
But I say, that's not valid.
That's not true.
In fact, there's always slip.
There's always velocity
and temperature slip.
It's just that normally it's
too small, so you can ignore it.
And you will see why downstream.
OK.
So conduction, convection.
STUDENT: Radiation.
GANG CHEN: Radiation,
let's look at radiation.
What's the radiation law?
OK, so let's write step
from Bolztmann q equals
for black body, sigma T4.
And the Stefan Bolztmann
constant, the 5.67 10
to the minus 8
watt meter squared.
And in this case
because it's not
linear with the
temperature, so you
have to use Kelvin,
Kelvin fourth power.
And I already commented before
we can go if we go nano.
We can go way beyond this.
OK.
So those are the
heat transfer laws.
I'm more ambitious.
I want to hear more.
If you're an electrical
engineer, you tell me,
well, chemical engineer.
What are the transport
laws of fluids?
These are the ones
that I'm familiar with.
STUDENT: Drift diffusion
for electric transport.
GANG CHEN: OK, drift diffusion.
Let me simplify it further.
Let's just write Ohm's law.
We'll derive drift fusion.
OK.
So here I have heat, and
I will have a charge.
And so Ohm's law, I wanted to
write that differential form.
So the differential
form for Ohm's law
is the current density.
So here is the flux.
Flux is the heat flux, is
a watt per meter squared.
Here current density is
m per meter squared, OK,
equals electrical conductivity
times the electrical field.
Right?
OK.
So here I have amp
meters squared.
And here I have, uh-oh, inverse
Ohm, inverse Ohm per meter.
That doesn't look like
a differential form.
So I'm going to write it
into a differential form,
electric field is the
derivative of potential.
So I have sigma and d, phi dx.
And I should have minus sign.
So phi is electrostatic
potential.
OK.
So that's for charge.
[? More, ?] we
talked about heat.
We talked about charge.
[? Fluid ?] [? guy, ?] tell me.
STUDENT: Momentum.
GANG CHEN: Momentum, OK.
Newton's Shear Stress law,
related force to the momentum.
So Newton's Shear Stress
law, Shear Stress,
and this is-- again, if I
take the simplest picture.
If I have x, I have
y and in the fluids,
there's Shear stress tau xy.
And in the simplest form,
tau xy equals mu du/dy dy.
This is the velocity [? u. ?]
This is the velocity wave.
So here we have
dynamical viscosity.
The Shear stress is
Newton meter squared
and the dynamics we've got
is the Newton's second meter
squared.
OK.
So we have Newton's
Shear Stress law.
And you can write into
more complex tensor form
3D, always writing
the simplest one.
What else?
Mass Tell me mass.
Transport.
STUDENT: Fick's law.
GANG CHEN: Fick's law.
Fick's law.
So mass, we have.
We have heat.
We have have.
So we have mass diffusion.
And the mass flux
equals rho, D and dc/dx.
The mass flux here you say is
a kilogram per meter squared.
Flux is always [INAUDIBLE]
times meter squared.
This [? now ?] is
density, diffusivity
is meter squared per second.
And this c is the mass fraction.
You can go to check the unit.
So we wrote all this
constitutive equation.
And in the first homework,
you were deriving.
So even though, say
in most of the classes
you're probably given, but you
can use the simplest picture
by counting the numbers.
And if you have a
gradient of velocity,
you have gradient of
temperature, you have gradient.
You have electrical field.
You'll see that this can be--
When you go to see
the granular picture,
those laws can be
easily derived.
And I'll show you in
the lecture next lecture
how to derive them.
OK.
So we say that those
are the continuum.
Those are the ones at
least you feel comfortable.
And the question we ask
is when we go to nano,
are those still valid.
If they are not valid,
what alternatives we have?
And to do that, we need
to go to granular picture.
We need to look at
the individual chart,
individual molecules,
and individual photons.
So what we are going
to look at next.
Let's take a look out of the
simplest microscopical picture
for this transport.
OK.
So let's first look at the--
we talk about heat.
That's what I'm
most familiar with.
So let's first
talk about the heat
and let's say heat conduction.
So we draw this picture
when one side is hot.
The other side is cold.
We see there is a heat flow.
And now I want to
look at the granular.
Let's say I have a
box with molecules.
Let's say one side is hot
the other side is cold.
And let's say we have
gas molecules inside.
How heat is actually conducted?
All right.
I'm sorry?
This molecule.
So I take the simplest guess.
There's no vibration.
I take helium.
STUDENT: Solutions colliding
with each other and the latest
[INAUDIBLE] for
the kinetic energy.
GANG CHEN: So this
side is hotter.
And the gas molecule,
they do random motion.
When I say random motion about
half of them will go this way,
and they were colliding
with the [INAUDIBLE]
at higher temperature.
And what they gain is they
gain a higher kinetic energy
because this is a
higher temperature.
When they bounce back, they have
higher kinetic energy faster.
So we begin energy when
the collision, and they
bounce back.
The next molecule they say will
have slightly lower energy.
So it's the two-ball
collision problem.
And during that process,
they'll pass some of the energy
to the next molecule, and
the next molecule against
have different chance going
this way and that way.
And it's that diffusion
process that he
goes from hot to the cold.
Right.
So it's the random walk
and diffusion process.
And in fact, it turns out other
than radiation [? orders ?]
are similar process.
OK.
And this is not an easy
picture in the history of heat
because way long time ago
people have this heat is there
something, [? calorie called. ?]
When you have to object
touching each other, the
[? calorie ?] flow from one
side to the other.
So when you go to
the supermarket,
you still have the
[? calories. ?]
It's a wrong concept.
We use the terminology today.
Now this is a gas molecule.
What about metal?
What carries heat in metal.
STUDENT: Electrons.
GANG CHEN: So electrons, right?
So I put the metal, and
what's the transport picture?
One side is hot.
The other side is cold.
Hmm?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: So
that's the picture.
So the electron now is
the gas in the solid.
They're bound by the
ions, but they actually
can mold quite a few
distances beyond.
Their not just to say that
these are free electrons.
The electron actually
can move around,
and again they will have
a collision distance.
We said that the air
molecule collision distance
is about 100 nanometer.
An electron collision distance
can be a few nanometer
to even longer, 100 nanometer.
Or your micron depends
on temperature.
So isn't it amazing
[? minutes ?]
of atom if you
think of 1 micron.
How many atoms there?
And the electron can zip
through them and no collision.
So of course at the end
there is a collision.
So if you think about that
case is the electron, power,
a few distance,
and they collide.
And that's the same process.
So it's the electron gas.
Will you give a name like a gas?
OK.
And next what about
a normal non-metal.
Diamond?
It's a phonon, OK.
But most of you probably-- the
first time I heard phonon--
in fact, not the first
time I heard phonon,
but I remember when I was
a graduate student walking
into an electrical engineering
that you have an open house--
They have an open
house with a lab show.
I said, I work on heat transfer.
And the guy said, oh,
you work on phonons.
And then most
mechanical engineer
when they work heat
transfer they don't know
what to do with the phonon.
And some-- none
you probably just
as a graduate from undergraduate
degree, mechanical engineering.
How many of you have heard of
the phonon in heat transfer
course?
Polarity.
OK.
So what is a phonon?
I had a once--
I was teaching at a
another university,
and I had a colleague.
And he sat in my class,
and he said I still
don't know what is a phonon.
What do what is a photon?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
STUDENT: So phonon?
GANG CHEN: Huh?
STUDENT: It's like a
vibration through a lattice.
GANG CHEN: It is
a vibration, yes.
Yeah.
It's another electron.
So let's say what
is the a long metal.
Dielectric let's see
first [INAUDIBLE]..
So what holds the material
together is the force?
And if I think about
two atoms in a material,
and the potential between the
two atom that's a typical curve
is like this.
This is the separation
between the two.
And this is the
potential energy.
This is the minimum point.
That's normally their
separation distance.
When they are further away,
they attract each other.
And when they're too
close, they repulse
each other because there
is a charge in [? them. ?]
Every atom has a positive
charge and negative charge.
At the end is the charge.
That's the glue for the
force, for the potential
of any material.
OK.
And so that's the force
that's the minimum distance.
And of course, the
potential and the force
is the force is the gradient
of potential [? u. ?] OK.
And at this minimum point
that first order of gradient
is zero.
So I can write the--
in fact, I can write the
potential this [INAUDIBLE]
if I do the expansion.
And I will write the force
roughly the potential expansion
first order is zero.
The second order
give me linear term.
That's a sprint.
So the two atoms, the potential,
the simplest approximation
is a spring holding
them together.
OK.
So when I have a
crystal like diamond,
it's a periodic
arrangement of atoms.
So they have their
equilibrium position,
and they are holding
together by these springs.
So this spring, now
you have this network.
You look at it.
It has a vibration.
And the vibration has
a different frequency.
So when we have vibration
frequency, frequency, mu.
And this is where it has
to go to quantum mechanics.
And it turns out that the
vibrational energy cannot be
arbitrary.
And the energy has to
be multiple of n h mu.
The h is the a Planck constant.
6.6 to the-- I only remember
if you are a physicist,
they'll laugh at me.
This is h times 6
jar times second
because the physicists
use atomical unit.
They don't carry this
large negative numbers.
But I only remember
the SI unit, so I
carry that large number, a small
number, the Planck constant.
h is Planck constant.
So what this says is that
the basic energy is h mu.
That's the [? quanta. ?]
That's the fundamental unit
of the vibrational energy.
And that fundamental
unit is called a phonon.
It's not like a electron.
It has a mass.
But say it's very
similar to photon.
Photon don't have a mass.
It turns out.
The photon has the frequency,
and the fundamental unit,
again, is h, mu for photon.
And in fact, later on you
learn a Planck relation,
the energy is always related
to frequencies through h mu.
OK.
So the phonon is quantitized
vibrational energy
in the material.
A phonon is a one quanta
of that vibration.
So if you do that
and going through,
this is where you will have to
wait probably until chapter 5
that it will go from
the vibrational modes.
It's a wave.
We say eventually I treat them
as particles and as a phonon
gas.
So I go from that
wave picture mode
to a gas picture in the solid.
So for the heat conduction it's
the phonon gas in the solid.
And once I think about the
gas, it's the same picture.
When one side is hard,
that phonon gas [INAUDIBLE]
to gain higher energy.
And they go to
[? less, ?] so the phonon
mean free pass, again, the
collision between the phonons.
And it turns out that
it's a wide range.
And we're doing quantum
calculations on this.
And some of them is 1 nanometer.
Others is 1 micron.
OK.
So for heat conduction
that basic picture
is this gas picture.
That's why I'm treating
phonon, electron and photon.
At the end there's a photon gas.
And they just say the
photon from the sun
when we traded the
photon gas-- but they
don't obey the diffusion
laws like the Fourier law.
They go ballistic.
There's no scattering
until they reach the Earth.
OK.
So that's the
conduction convection.
What's the difference?
Microscopic pressure
for convection.
We say, OK, you
have [INAUDIBLE]..
And the ambient we gave
the Newton flow of cooling.
So what's the microscopic
picture of convection?
What's the difference
from conduction?
STUDENT: Non-zero
average [INAUDIBLE]..
GANG CHEN: Yeah,
very good answer.
So what in heat conduction is
molecules are moving randomly.
And they are moving at a 300
meter per second, pretty fast.
But their average
velocity vector is 0.
So for the conduction, we have
the average velocity zero,
but for convection
this is not zero.
OK.
And that could be 1 meter per
second to meter per second.
But I said the
molecules are always
doing random motion 300
meter per second much faster.
But you know convection
is more effective.
That's because they
are not a diffusion,
because when they move from
one place to another place,
they carry all that
energy directly
from one place to another.
The energy [? is in ?]
[? enthalpy. ?] So
that's the fundamental
difference.
You still got those
random motions.
So when you go back to think
about Navier-Stokes equation,
you still have heat
conduction term there.
That random motion
is still there,
but you got a convective term.
OK.
So that's a convection.
And in fact, if you
take that, convection
is almost the same
as conduction,
except rather than-- it just
have a direct [? momentum. ?]
So I would say it's
fundamental is not too new
a picture at this scale.
And then we think
about radiation, right?
What's a thermal radiation?
What's the radiation
from a radial?
What's the difference?
STUDENT: The gases
are [INAUDIBLE]..
GANG CHEN: Huh?
STUDENT: The gas
are [INAUDIBLE]..
GANG CHEN: So the radiation
from the heat source
is the photon, the radiation,
electromagnetic wave
from radial source.
We normally don't
call it the photon.
It's also a photon.
It is an o-photon.
An o-photon in free
space, you learn
this at high school, the speed
of light, wavelength frequency.
Which channel do you turn?
What's the frequency?
I turn to 98.5.
But I forgot that megahertz
or kilohertz, though.
It doesn't matter.
Is it megahertz or
kilohertz do I think?
Anybody remember?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: I can't.
So let me just
put 100 kilohertz.
I know there are
200 kilohertz range.
And so what's the
wavelength, speed of light.
3, 10 to the eighth
meter per second.
So that gives me wavelength
10 to the fifth 10
to the eighth and kilometer.
OK.
So it's a photon, and
the energy is h, mu.
That low energy photon.
And it's generated by-- you
know that station, right--
an oscillating current generate
this electromagnetic wave.
It's an oscillating current.
So artificially you oscillate.
What's the thermal radiation?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: Huh?
STUDENT: It takes
vibrational frequency.
GANG CHEN: It's a
vibrational frequency
that's the-- what is that?
OK.
It is covering a wide
range of frequency.
But there's still
oscillating current.
I don't think, see, all
radiation is a thermal motion.
It's just thermally generated
oscillating current.
And think about the atoms.
Think about electrons.
One electron, move it
around, the general color.
So it's the thermally
random motion generated,
and this is a much smaller
oscillator much faster.
So if you think
about wavelengths.
It's the 0.5 micron.
It's 0.5 10 to the minus 6.
This is 10 to the 14 then.
Frequency is 10 to 14, is a
lot longer, 100 kilohertz.
OK.
So that's the big difference.
But let's say in
terms of propagation
of thermal radiation, it's
actually the same [? maximum ?]
equation.
It's not different from what
the electrical engineer does.
It's the source
that's different.
Once they are out
the propagation,
you write the same equation.
OK.
So at the end, there
are not many equations.
And so that's the heat transfer.
We can go other.
We can pick up another object,
subject here, let's say charge.
Ohm's law.
I want to show you easily
how I can derive Ohm's law.
And let's look at the charge.
And of course, I do
a lot of hand-waving.
And I have a
conductor, electrons.
I have a potential.
What's the force
on the electron?
Anybody remember if I have
a charge I have potential.
If my potential is E, let's
say this is an x-direction.
The force fx equals
charge times the field.
So it's minus e times Ex.
This is what I really hate.
The minus I often get confused.
OK.
So I have [? force. ?]
And I'm going to write
Newtons second law, f equal ma.
So this is a m, dvx/dt.
F equal ma.
And it turns out that
what the electron does,
we mentioned before, it collide.
It can go certain distance.
Then it collide.
So the acceleration time
is between the collision.
Collide, actually,
collide, actually.
So I'm going to give you a hand
even if I do that integration I
say that's tau.
That's the average time
between the collision.
So my velocity then is
if I integrate this.
I get the E epsilon X
divided by m times tau.
This is the drift, the velocity.
The electron at the end is
sort of under this field.
There's a moment average
velocity of the charge.
OK.
And now if I have this velocity,
I can write the current.
The current, what's current?
Current is just the
charge per unit time
going across a certain area.
So if I look at the
current because if we
access the average velocity.
So if I know the charge
density per unit volume,
then I write my J
equals the current.
Jx is the charge that's in
column times n and times vx.
That's my current density.
If you look at the unit
E. Anyone remember?
Again.
1.6, 10 to the minus 19 column.
OK, one charge.
Again, I remember SI unit.
And here is 1 over a
meter cubic because that's
charge density per unit volume.
And then you do this
meter per second.
And you get that
here is a column
per meter squared per second.
Column per meter square
is m per meter squared.
That's your current density.
So if I plug-in
there, what I have
is e squared and tau, n
times n times epsilon x.
That's Ohm's law.
This is my electric
conductivity.
This is sigma epsilon, x.
OK.
Let's do another then.
So I have heat.
I have charge.
I have a lot of
thing about force.
Let's think about the
momentum, the pressure.
Let's say we have
heat charge, momentum.
OK.
What's the pressure?
When you have a box of
gas, you have pressure.
What is that pressure?
STUDENT: Of course the
gasing is over [? an ?] area.
GANG CHEN: So is the gas--
I have a box.
I have gas inside.
I have molecules.
They are moving.
They are moving randomly.
And the pressure is--
when the gas hit the wall,
and they will change
direction, bounce back.
There's a momentum change.
That momentum change
gives you the force.
So I can argue with you inside.
I don't know what's
the pressure.
Now you stick to your
[INAUDIBLE] there.
You measure that
momentum change,
and you measure the pressure.
OK.
So here is, of
course, the force.
Let's say is fx on the wall
is a single marker is vx.
This larger than 0 mass nvx less
than zero divided by delta, t.
So that's the single molecule
acting on the wall of force.
Now I want to find the
pressure in the chamber.
I have a lot of molecules.
Again, the density,
molecular density n,
and they are coming towards
their wall and bounce back.
So let me just make my
simplest perfecting wall.
So the coming velocity equals
the bouncing back velocity.
So it's a factor of 2.
And I have a lot
of molecules here.
This molecular density
is n to random.
So half of them coming
towards the wall.
So is one half n, and
in terms of the rate
the time comes is still vx.
That's the rate.
That's the rate they're coming.
And this gave me
the delta-t I need.
And then say I have 2mvx.
I'm assuming like I said this
vx is just reflecting back.
So this will give me pressure.
Again you go to check a unit.
OK.
So what I get?
I get this pressure
equals nmvx squared.
vx squared is the velocity
component, x direction squared.
So it's just one third,
roughly speaking, homogenized.
So it's one third of v squared.
OK, so what I have here is
nm, one third v squared.
OK.
Now I want to show
you ideal gas law.
And v squared.
And this is-- You have to go.
You have to wait a little bit.
But then let me give
you the equal partition.
That's a statistical
thermal, says
here equals nv squared because
it has three vxv by zbz.
So each of these modes will
give you this Boltzmann
constant times t.
So this one you're with,
statistical thermal,
fundamental result,
equal partition.
OK.
So I plug-in this.
What I have?
That one third cancel that 3.
One half cancel
mv squared is kbt.
So what I have here
is then is nkbt,
and this is ideal gas law.
It still doesn't look
like ideal gas law.
One more step.
And one more step
and I'll stop here.
OK.
So n is the number of
molecules per unit volume.
So I multiply volume.
So I have PV equals number
of molecules times Boltzmann
constant times t.
It doesn't look like an r yet.
So I do n divided by na,
Avogadro constant, na, kdt.
And this is your r.
That's your universal
gas constant.
And this is your mole
fraction, mole fraction,
times your r, universal
gas consent, times t,
pv equals [? nrt. ?] Ideal
gas law, times wavelength.
I'm not doing
rigorously of course.
OK.
So anyone remember, knows kB.
What's the number,
Boltzmann constant?
STUDENT: 1.38 [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: 1.38 10 to the
minus 23 jar per Kelvin.
OK.
So you go to look at
Avogadro constant, 20
is it's about 6x10 to the 23.
You cancel.
6 times 1.3 give you--
That's the universal
gas constant.
OK.
So basically where
we're going is
to look at those
microscopic picture
and look at the electrons,
look at the photons,
look at molecule photons,
and count this end,
count how many we have, count
how much energy they have,
and count how long they travel.
And with that you can
do all the counting.
So the host thread
line for the transport
is accounting the basic thing,
the microscopic carriers.
And for that we need to go
in another, more detail.
OK.
So any questions?
We'll stop here.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: Oh, yeah, I
send a questionnaire.
I would like to fill it
and hand it back to me
so that I can have some idea
what's your background, what's
your interest.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
GANG CHEN: OK.